another video we have to use the
microphone and also
um when did you guys have questions
initially if there's a microphone over
here so and
a video
so we'll just wait about another minute
and then we'll get started
all right guys we'll get started and
then if someone some other folks come in
that would be
is this on
I think I still can yell louder than
okay well thanks for coming to our
presentation
um as you can see the title of it is
moocs's collaborative tools to support
teacher learning and we're going to talk
a little bit about how we went about
designing a collaborative C mooc but a
little bit about who we are first my
name is Sarah Rutherford Kwok and I'm
the director of academics and research
as well as a lecturer at Stanford
University the name of our initiative
it's like a center but it has more
momentum we're called an initiative is
understanding language and so the focus
of our initiative is basically
um to this says our mission is this but
it's actually not
um but our new mission is to assist
teachers as they support all students so
this is K-12 teachers so we're focused
on K-12 teachers but especially those
teachers of English language Learners
are Second Language by student bilingual
students in developing both content
knowledge and language we're very timely
and that the Common Core State Standards
who knows about the Common Core State
Standards all right I figured if you
came to this presentation you probably
did
um but for those of you that don't the
Common Core State Standards are rolled
out
I think two years ago last year there
but they're really rolled out this year
and they are very language heavy in that
they um
they require students all students to
really Express their learning in the
content areas in language and so that is
our focus of our our Center and so my
background I've heard a lot of people at
this conference say that they're an
outsider but I think that must not be
true because if everyone says it but I I
just wanted to give you a little
background about what my training is in
I'm actually a linguistic Anthropologist
of education and so I got my my PhD at
Stanford and I work a lot so I used to
be a bilingual kindergarten teacher and
then ended up going back to um to
graduate school and so a lot of the
people that work at our organization
were I mean no one was a mooc expert if
there is such a thing as a mooc expert
before we started this and so the
purpose of the mooc was really I mean
the mooc was a means to an end so we
were by no means doing the moocs for
mooc's sake we're doing them as we'll
talk about later as tools for for not
just mostly in-service teachers K-12
teachers that are already in the
classroom
so that's a little bit about me and the
organization and I'm going to let
chaolin um
so I'm xiaolinxia I work on the
technology part of our project so it's
like in the spring quarters we actually
have four courses at the same time and I
was that administrator for those four
courses and I can say we can tell you
that well if you have four courses
together you could still survive
we're trying to figure out if anyone
else did four at the same time
barely survived yeah
um so that's a little bit about our
organization background and what our
purpose was in conducting these moocs
and then our presentation structure for
today we've we've been to a few of these
you know yesterday
um both smaller ones and bigger ones and
it's a little bit the 15 minutes and the
45 minutes is a little bit uh across the
board and what people have done what
we're going to do is we're going to do
two parts to the presentation and the
first part is we're going to talk about
how we design our mooc for collaboration
our original mooc the pilot mooc and
then we're gonna stop and have you ask
questions because we know that the way
that I mean we're learning we didn't
know it at the time actually that the
way that we designed our mooc is quite
different than how a lot of moocs out
there are designed and so we anticipate
our hope that there's going to be some
clarification questions and how that
actually happened
um and then the second part we're going
to talk about was the mooc successful
and how we divine define success with
how we did Define it and how we're
defining it as we move forward or maybe
how we should Define it
um both with respect to learning
outcomes and collaboration and we should
tell you um well I'll tell you in a
second our first mooc was um this was
the title of it so you can see where the
linguistic anthropology of Education
comes in it was constructive classroom
conversations mastering language for the
common core and we were three
instructors myself and Kenji hakuta
who's a professor at Stanford and he's a
psycho linguist
um and then Jeff sweers who is all he's
a senior researcher at Stanford and his
specialty is teacher professional
development and language in the content
areas and my specialty was I mean it's
starting to become more moocs and
language but
um was discourse and so Kenji came up to
me and said Sarah I was a postdoc for
understanding language and he said do
you want to do a mooc and I said it was
a mooc and this is about a year and a
half ago and so the mooc a lot of it
came out of Jeff's work and my
dissertation research and
um
we really did not know how to like we
knew what moocs were but we didn't know
exactly the typical way to run a mooc
and so we signed up for a bunch of them
and frankly some of them were great but
some of them I wasn't that impressed
with
um and so the thing that because we are
yesterday at the panel how many of you
are at the dinner at the
so a few of you heard this
um the man from the UK talked about
being a social constructivist
um and so our organization is very much
built on the idea that learning happens
through discourse it happens through
discussion and so an ex mooc didn't make
a lot of sense for us at all
um it wasn't in in line with our values
it wasn't the way that we believed that
learning happens best and it
particularly wasn't the way that we
believe learning happens with teachers
who is our target audience and so it was
very important to us that we had a c
mooc but just not not just community so
this is the way that we Define a simuch
and it's also kind of cute because our
class our course is called constructive
classroom conversations so we call it
the CCC mooc
um so I keep hitting the down button
sorry
um so in our case the same part is the
constructionist or constructivist which
I had to put in there because I know
that both terms are used but we also
focus on collaboration and community
building and they overlap a lot and you
can see with um in the circles of the
Venn diagram our collaboration includes
not only higher education and not just
Stanford we're actually working with a
lot of different universities now we
have collaborations with Berkeley one of
our pis is actually a professor at
Berkeley Oregon State
um well who else
I think that might the oh UCLA and UC
Santa Cruz so those are our and New York
State and a few up down the pike but we
also have collaborations and and
beginning to have more collaborations
with States
um but also the collaborations in the
and the community building that we care
the most about are the people that we
want to take the mooc so those are the
teachers the coaches and the
administrators at the mooc is directed
towards
um and so that was our first pilot and I
wanted to say and we actually have a
Novo at uh delicate here so Ann here is
from Noble Ed so she can answer your
questions about that when we stop for
discussion so we wanted all of these
things they were really important to us
so we actually very purposefully chose
to go with novoed as a platform provider
because they allowed for collaborative
teams and that's what we're going to
talk a lot about today collaborative
teams what does that mean for mooc
participants what are the constraints
and the affordances of collaborative
teams so we looked around a lot and we
decided to go with novaud because that
was one of their Foci was being able to
have collaborative teams and also
participant profile so that that the
students could we call the mooc students
participants because they have their own
K2 students so if I talk about
participants and I don't like the word
users very much because it seems very
not that collaborative so the
participants
um and so we've actually done five
different moocs and we did four in the
spring and we did one in the fall and
two of the ones in the spring were
second iterations of the first mooc and
so this is how we're going to talk a
little bit about design design based
research and research-based design how
we learned from the first mooc what the
kind of mistakes that we made and then
how we changed it in the future and
we're kind of lucky because we're going
to do a third iteration because a lot of
districts and states are asking us to
and so I'm not sure out there who gets
to do you know many iterations of moocs
a because it takes a lot of money right
I know Joe bowler at Stanford has done
two very similar ones and I'm sure
there's people out there that have but
this is lucky for us because we get it's
kind of built in research um and then
we've also done two other moocs one was
on mastering language in mathematics for
the Common Core
and the other was on formative
assessment
um and so formative assessment was
actually really it was a need in the
field
so the smarter balanced Consortium
um which is part of it's related to the
new common Common Core State Standards
actually asked us to do this and so it
was a little bit of an experiment
um and so like I said we really really
the C mooc was very important to us um
and this is kind of a quick graphic of
our philosophy of the moocs what the
type of learning cycle that we wanted to
facilitate was the idea that the
teachers would listen to their students
conversations to find out what was going
on better understand them so that they
could act on them and so we needed to be
able to design a mooc that would allow
for that and so obviously you're not
going to be able to do that if the
assignments that you have are basically
quizzes
so we the assignments that we um
designed were very purposeful and they
have four steps and I have plan a little
bit darker here than collect because in
the first step we talked a little bit
about this morning about um a motivation
strategy to have people understand the
problem or to build prior knowledge and
so myself as a teacher I know that a lot
of times I thought I understood what was
going on with the language of my
students or what they were saying in
small groups but I really didn't and so
when I listened carefully or I use a
recorder to record my students and then
actually listen to it there was a bunch
of ahas that I didn't realize before and
we wanted our participants to have that
so our first assignment actually
involved them collecting actual language
data for them their classroom reflecting
and then transcribing a part of that
reflecting on that and then acting on it
and then we actually just repeated this
plan collect reflect act for four
different assignments which is another I
mean you can probably guess from what
I'm saying all of our assignments were
classroom based so you had to have
access to a classroom which really you
know kind of minimizes the massiveness
of it because you a you have to be a
teacher or a coach and B you have to
have access to a classroom so a
conversation I had with my mother in law
you really want to take the mooc she
thought that was really exciting and I
said you can take it but you have to be
an auditor because I don't think you
have access to a classroom so we do have
a slew of people that started and became
Auditors because of that so we knew it
would be constraining but it was also
very important it was part to the design
of the mooc
and then not only did we have these four
steps in each assignment we also had a
learning cycle that was very purposeful
and very iterative because what we
wanted the participants to gain was this
idea of discursive connoisseurship this
is a word that I made up
um so it's basically I credit Elliot
Eisner because he does lots of
connoisseurship so this is discursive so
it's the idea that you um
have enough of an understanding of the
language that's happening in your
classroom and how to support it to move
on and so what we wanted is we wanted
the participants to become connoisseurs
of the discourse in their classroom and
then know what to do about that so how
they could support it more and the way
that we um designs assignments were very
purposeful in that we had one assignment
that asked them to listen closely to
conversations
and then analyze that plan and design
instruction and then teach and reflect
so the the cycle just repeats and in
this this is actually an assessment
strategy too which it was interesting
this morning the talk um when dick was
talking about you don't realize what you
did like this we were this seemed very
evidence-based in the research that we
know from education but we also like
planned it this way where the first
assignment and the third assignment were
very similar to each other and that
actually worked really well to be able
to look at learning so we had a planned
in assignment already so when we looked
at the research of the evidence later on
we had that already done for
um so this is the cycle
um and then we also we wanted to talk
very very briefly about the
collaboration we don't just have
collaboration I talked about having
different universities
um but this is really kind of morphed
into a bigger thing than we had imagined
and so there's collaboration all these
little stars are basically some of our
collaborators and so we have
collaboration at Institutes of higher
education and then districts and States
as well but the different collaborators
are different interested in different
things so some of them actually want to
teach a mooc with us so Oregon state
they're doing that right now or it's
starting in October and Berkeley has
also done that but some of the other
collaborators are interested in other
parts of what we're calling like our
moocology or our Mosaic and I'm going to
have Chillin talk about this graphic
that she designed to explain that yes so
I think Sarah just mentioned that we
don't just do moocs for moocs we
actually have a bigger picture of that
put the mooc in our big design so
basically we'll use mooc I know Sarah
really hates this picture because that's
kind of the X move that would try to
avoid that I use a hair cell so we use
moocs as a LMS like learning management
system and then it's not only a way to
deliver the content to our participants
but also we use it as a way to collect
something called student language
samples so by offering the books we also
collect this data which we will we are
now collecting and try to build a
database and we hope that we can
actually I don't know in the future we
can share this database back to the
Educators parents or even students and
build up something called a
developmental linguistic continuance so
they get to see maybe for a third grade
classroom when they talk about climate
change or things like that what kind of
conversation will they look like so
that's from the mooc participation part
um we also Sarah also mentioned we
collaborate we are collaborating with
school districts and we also go into
their teachers classroom to
observe and videotaping their teaching
and we use those videos and then build a
video library and then these videos will
be used again back to the mooc it's more
like a customized content
and we also are collaborating with a um
open source um resources partner called
Guru so we're trying to build this whole
like learning system that's based on
open oer
and so you can imagine that different
people are interested in different parts
of this so the the student language
database there's researchers at
different universities who are super
excited about this so if this you know
plays out the way that we hope there
will be all this classroom data on
language and classroom that just doesn't
exist right now
um and so but then also the video
library and the guru things there's a
lot of people that are interested in
those aspects as well so not just the
teaching of the mooc so our
collaboration is a little bit bigger and
we just wanted to touch on that and we
know that this is the design base but we
wanted to let you know kind of what the
bigger picture was
um so we're going to pause for questions
um and I I I'm going to assume that some
of the questions are probably
clarification at this this time but you
obviously don't have to stick to these
um so if you have any questions about
the goals just general questions
questions about novoed we have Ann here
who can answer those as well and the
affordances and constraints of the
platform and as well as questions about
either how we collaborate with those
Partners or how we design the pilot move
for collaboration constructionism and
Community Building
so and Sharif has the mic yeah
um so I just had a question do you did
you have um an international audience as
well and how did you sort of manage that
against sort of
common core standards which and other
things which I assume are sort of unique
to the educate U.S educational system
with the things that are sort of
universal we did have an international
and it was actually a lot bigger than we
thought and especially for the pilot
mooc for the other moocs that we did
later on it was smaller
um but the skills that we're focusing on
I mean they're very relevant to the
common core but they're not they're not
only Common Core so they were very
relevant to other at least other
countries seem to have self-reported
that they were very relevant so it
really wasn't a problem if anything I
think we didn't focus on the link
between the common core and the skill
base as much as maybe we could have so
we basically once we started the mooc
we'd say okay this is important for the
common core but it wasn't something that
was essential to every assignment does
that make sense
what sort of aspects of collaboration
were you looking for trying to structure
and how did you structure those for for
participants for participants yes okay
so good question um at first we didn't
know we knew that
um in evidence-based in in person it was
important for professional development
for teachers to have up what's called a
PLC
um what does this stand for uh
professional learning community so we
tried to kind of emulate that PLC and
what we wanted was them to be able to
talk to someone about it so we always
use this uh this story so Kenji actually
went to a conference and there had
people it was in the South and so there
was tons of different districts and um
there was a teacher that there was
actually I think it was an administrator
that came up to him and said I have all
these teachers and it was in rural
Tennessee that are the only person in
their District or school and they have
all the English Learners in their
classroom so they do not have any other
peers to talk to about this and they
don't have access to high quality
professional development because it's
not a priority for the school district
and so what we wanted is we wanted to be
able to at least create a smaller
Community for those people so that they
could talk about it and that they could
have colleagues who are in similar
situations and the way that we
designed the first mooc and there were
some problems with this so we tried to
fix some of them in the second one is
that we had basically an individual
assignment and then we had a team
component to that assignment and so the
individual assignment you'd go into your
own classroom and talk about it and
collect the data and then you talk about
that with the team assignments and then
the final assignment was actually a team
assignment it worked better and worse
for some different teams one of the
problems is that people drop out
and so if you have a required team
assignment and there's nobody else left
on your team there was a little bit of
panic from people who weren't sure what
the procedure was to find another team
so you can so we tried to do the best we
could to to kind of fix that situation
in the second one whether that was
successful or not
and we're getting there but does that
answer your questions about yeah maybe
but you also indicated that perhaps they
were some of that collaboration was even
out not directly related to the
assignments that you were giving but
just general about practices that were
certainly relevant to the topic but
obviously to the assignments so did that
did that sort of grow in Blossom as well
it did and it's interesting in the first
book I think it happened more in the
discussion forum the main discussion
forum so the way that Nova had set up is
they're two different kinds of
discussion forum there's a team
discussion forum and then there's a like
a larger discussion forum the first
pilot mooc there was tons of activity on
the discussion forum but there was not
as much activity on the team discussion
forum so we tried to kind of do some
interventions to flip that a little bit
in the second move and it worked but
then the problem was there wasn't that
much larger group discussion for them
um so I think that did work we also
found out from our post surveys that a
lot of the people that signed up for the
mooc I mean I talked about the lone
Tennessee teacher so there was that
demographic but there was also a lot of
people who saw wind up with their
real-life colleagues so there was not
only
um people you know talking about things
online but they were talking about it in
person as well
hi uh well much of the questions that I
had in my mind or you've probably
answered already but I just want to
reiterate uh just for my for myself uh
the activities and the launching of the
collaborative program that you conducted
here how was it facilitated when it
became a critical mass in terms of the
number of people are participating and
and what was the incentive they had to
participate and to complete other than
some of them are required and the third
one was uh third one is basically it was
digital badge used uh in this entire
process
uh digital badge was not used
and then the second question you might
have to repeat the first but oh okay the
first is uh
how was it facilitated I mean did you
personally facilitated or if it was if
the population of the the users okay I
don't want to use the user facilitate
the team formation team formation as
well as to maintain and sustain yeah
okay let's have Ann talk about the team
formation because she's an expert on it
and then I'll talk about how we
maintained it but while she's getting
the mic I'll tell you about the second
one people's motivation
yeah so there there actually was this
was kind of organic because we didn't
talk to districts ahead of time about
this but what happened in a lot of cases
is that District administrators found
out about this mooc and they offered
professional development credit for
their teachers and so our treasurement
was pretty good
um but also we actually had a big
International presence as well and a lot
of people finished it internationally so
I don't know what those but what I do
know about is that Sacramento for
example gave professional development
credit
um Palo Alto where we are did as well
there's a couple districts in Maryland
that did so it just happened organically
but it did help a lot with attrition
would be different from traditional
I could
this project can be on that
framework instead of using Moon it could
it could but it was also really
important to us that it was open so for
example the Tennessee teacher back again
they did not have professional
development credit it was not a priority
and so it was really important to us
that we it was not a party for the
district it was a priority for that
person and so we wanted to be able to
reach those people as well and Kenji um
our PI is very adamant about this and we
actually and now we have a paid option
but we we've had
um solicitations to just have a paid
option and we won't do it because so now
what we have is a hybrid we have we
offer it for free but there's also a
paid option that comes along with some
other perks
do you want to answer his question
firsthand before sure so for the the
team formation the way the technology
works you have three options as an
instructor or facilitator one is is that
you can create the teams yourself so if
we have a lot of classes that are two
three four hundred people and people are
grouped by school districts or what have
you
um but what these guys used was what we
call the organic team formation so we
have organic team formation and
algorithmic team formation algorithmic
to information you set criteria the
system runs an algorithm sorts people
into teams yeah sometimes work sometimes
doesn't because people get thrown into
teams and then they have to do a lot of
extra social work to kind of introduce
themselves to each other and say hey
we're here and get moving if you move
that work to the formation part of the
team and organic teams go find people to
work with and they the students can use
those criteria that you set themselves
then they we see across courses that
those teams tend to be more active and
those students are more engaged and so
you just put the administration of the
class basically onto the teachers and
teachers are happy to do that they know
how it works so and so you can scale you
know it's it may be a 50 000 person
class but if you have a team of five
it's just ten thousand teams of five
right so just ten thousand which by the
way we've never actually done we've had
50 000 people in the class but not
everybody
and we did the organic teams and the
reason we did the organic teams I mean
it's very practical right so we had we
had people in our mooc that were
kindergarten teachers and people who
were physics teachers in high school and
it made no sense for them necessarily to
be on the same team for our purpose for
some other purpose it may have made
sense but because we were specifically
studying classroom language which is
very content specific we wanted people
to be able to form their own teams and
it worked pretty well
um and I'm going to show you a little
bit later like some of the the results
that we had and the analysis
is there some more question back there
yeah um how did you Market the courses
that's good um it's pretty ad hoc um
um in in our world and our world is
starting to become the mooc world but it
has been the the language in the K-12
world
understand language has a big presence
and so in districts and schools and it's
very lucky that it did because we didn't
Market it very much so novoed marketed
it on their site Stanford marketed it
which is also a big presence but as far
as us going out and kind of finding
people to be in it or being more
strategic about it we weren't we weren't
super strategic about it and so I think
we kind of lucked out the first round we
because we're doing several iterations
of it we're going to have to Market it
more
um because you know once you do the same
content more than one time you're going
to have this excited group of people the
first time who check Stanford online but
we want to reach the people that are not
checking Stanford online and so we are
in the process of figuring out how to do
that and I think because our target
audience is Teachers the way that we're
going to Market it is through districts
and states
over here
yeah
first of all I want to say I'm like
really excited about this because I um
well also interested in like training
teachers and doing professional
development through moocs I guess a
couple questions I had were like on size
how big was it and like how did you
manage because I know you were talking
about how I was kind of crazy with four
but yeah what was it moment for the
pilot moves about nine thousand yeah and
then they were about like
totally active throughout the course and
then for the spring courses I think each
course is about 2 000 people yeah and
then like was it just you all or was it
just you all then just you yeah so no
not just us two so us two and our team
we are lucky in the way that so this
morning when dick was talking about you
know you need a team of folks so our
team has a fairly diverse I think we
need some more people still
um but we basically the instructors and
chelin and uh ta Diego Roman who's now
an assistant professor um at TCU um we
met every week for like four hours a
week
um and so we were very intense but and
then now as we've gotten bigger we've
hired you know more people to help us
um psychometricians and things like that
but we it was the first time around I
mean it's kind of like a startup right
so and then my second like big question
was like uh I guess maybe you'll get
into this but like how did the student
the participants took it during the
semester during the class yeah and like
what were their experiences like do they
have trouble staying on and was it
interesting like I mean I'm trying to
understand that part no it's a great
question it's very relevant so it's
especially a great question because our
assignments were difficult I mean they
weren't doing you know like I said they
weren't like online quizzes or or
multiple choice questions you had to get
in your class and do it and take the
extra time to do that so we did have in
our post survey we definitely had people
we definitely had people drop out
because they didn't have time for it
um but the good thing is the people that
did stay really prioritize it and we
think that they learned a lot from it
but moving forward we're trying to find
a way to streamline some of the
assignments so that
maybe some of the extraneous material
that might be repetitive in some ways we
pull out or something like that but to
keep the you know the flavor of the and
the main gist of the assignments
so you mentioned uh kind of stumbling
into the professional continuing credit
and districts actually giving Teachers
Credit
um yeah which is great and fascinating
um I'm curious this second time around
if that's part of the design in thinking
a marketing but also B the design to say
you know XYZ districts will take credit
for X hours and if you're starting to
factor that in and how are you doing it
I guess what are those conversations
yeah no it's we're are doing it from
various angles and so we actually have
for the second course we had a paid
option and so what the paid option
bought you which we're going to redesign
for the third option the third course
because I think some of it works some of
it didn't is that the the paid option
bought you basically a document that
said how many professional development
hours it was equivalent to and that and
it also it's called a record of
completion so you get a free statement
of accomplishment if you from novoed
when you finish it if you go for the
paid option you get a record of
completion from Stanford Graduate School
of Education and the biggie for the paid
option is not only do you get like oh
this is equivalent of 30 hours of
professional development you get your
work evaluated by us and so one thing
one huge thing I forgot to talk about in
the assignments is that all of the
assignments are peer evaluated and so
that was that was required in the
assignment
um and so each person had to evaluate
five of their peers
um on and we had you know different
metrics for the assignment so some of
the metrics were about the conversation
itself but the ones that we used to
measure growth were actually about how
the participant reflected on the
conversation how they analyzed the
conversation things like that their
growth
um so if you get a free statement then
you can you can have that peer
evaluation still but if you get a paid
one then you get it from the actual
instructors or the Now it worked sort of
it I it's kind of funny because you know
we did this course on formative
assessment it wasn't very formative
um it was very like summative at the end
and we'd like to be able to identify
people earlier and part of the problem
is we were kind of doing this on the Fly
and so we did the paid option like two
weeks after the course started and so
um
and so they we didn't Market it until it
happened and then we're like hey you can
have this paid option
um and but and we also weren't able a
lot of people at the end were like oh I
want the paid option but I think it
would be more powerful if you could
actually have feedback throughout and
then as far as districts and who don't
want to do the paid option don't need to
because they're already agreed to the
professional vote which there's a lot of
them we've started a formal relationship
with a few and one of them we're going
to talk about a little bit it's actually
we started a hybrid model
um with
um a pretty decently sized district and
so they actually offer it and I'll talk
more about it in a second because it's a
little complicated but if you take the
hybrid model then they offer
professional development and we're
talking with a couple States like LA and
New York and LAUSD which is like a state
basically uh
do the same thing
does that answer the question
should we move on all right okay so
here's the the nitty-gritty stuff so was
the mooc successful and how did do or
should we define success both with
respect to learning outcomes and
collaboration
so here are some outcomes to measure
success so this morning when I was
laying in bed looking at the um the
agenda for today I thought this guy had
a really good title about from fishing
in the exhaust have you guys seen that
so some of this is fishing in the
exhaust actually quite a bit of it is we
spent a lot of time designing the mooc
for collaboration we did not spend as
much time trying to figure to pre-plan
um ways that we could do research about
we did a little bit I mean because the
instructors did all you know a lot of
the planning of it and we're doing the
research but
um the second and third iteration we did
a much better job of that but we did
look at you know what everyone looks at
so attrition completion and use rates we
also had a pre and post survey where we
had self-reported learning and
satisfaction we also did a couple we
actually did one
um basically a group a focal group where
we got a bunch of teachers in person who
had taken the mooc and we did basically
a qualitative interview with them where
we asked them what did you think of it
what are what are your suggestions you
know what were the highlights uh very
similar to the survey but that we could
get more detail about it and then we did
look at a few evidence of learning and
it was a little bit of a mistake but a
good one um is that we were able to look
at the assignments content and
completion especially assignments one
and three because they were very
iterative and they um they we use them
as a good measure of learning and then
we also looked did a qualitative
analysis of the team participation so we
looked at the team blogs and this was
about three-fourths of the way through
so this actually was pretty formative so
we looked and and part of it was due to
because I looked at it and I was like ah
these teams aren't participating as much
why and so we went through and and I you
know basically just slogged through the
team blogs to try to find out what was
going on
um and you know it wasn't a it
definitely was an experiment because I
would send them an email and be like uh
we would really like you to do this and
but we got a lot of information that way
the one the different measures of
evidence of learning that we did not do
but that we have done in the second
iteration are pre and post assessments
now it's very different to do a pre and
post assessment than a pre and post
survey so when you're getting self-set
like reported learning outcomes like
that's fine I can say I learned a lot
but whether or not I did is you know I
don't know and so what we did is we
basically put a three questions into the
survey that focused on the skill that we
wanted them to learn through the course
which is how to you know this discursive
connoisseurship look at a conversation
look at a transcript of a conversation
what are the what are the positives of
this this conversation and what things
stand out to you are the students
building on each other's turns are they
focused on a certain thing and then to
be able to evaluate that which is what
they did in the assignments and so that
actually was really helpful for us to
look at that
um and then on the ground classroom
observations and so we didn't do a lot
of these as you can we were pretty busy
but the district that we partnered with
was able to do this and they were able
to videotape the hybrid participants and
so we actually haven't analyzed them yet
but we're trying to for the second one
because they were actually able to
videotape the participants as they're
going through the moocs and so we can
actually what what we want to do which
is very difficult is to eventually look
at the student student learning outcome
measures and I don't mean standardized
tests I mean art is the skill that we
are focusing on the conversation skills
are they actually happening in the
classroom and the closest way that we've
gotten to that so far are these
classroom observations but we're open to
suggestions about how we could do it
besides that
um and so here's our completion right
for the first course
so the raw completion rate you might be
used to this here Chillin I'll let you
explain it so so the wrong one is like
it's based on like how many people sign
up for the course and then well I think
numbers pretty similar to other books
around six percent but then there's also
the other the actual completion rate
which is respect to people who finish
the first assignment and then the rate
is about 26 percent
there you go oh sorry that's okay
um but teams and completion so this was
interesting right so we did some
analysis and we found that being on a
team was highly correlated with
completing the course like crazy Lee
highly correlated that is not surprising
because we basically said you need to be
on a team
but what's surprising to us was being on
a larger team of four or more people was
correlated with a higher completion rate
and so a team can actually be anywhere
from one to eight people we didn't tell
anybody they could be a team of one like
why promote that
um so in our case you know we said it
could be two to eight people but there
were people who figured it out they're
going to definitely be smarter than us
and had a team of one
um but if you were on a team that of
those small teams actually a lot of
times tended to fizzle out which makes
sense if you have a team member and you
only have one other person and they drop
out they have a baby or whatever then
you kind of you have to find a new team
which which requires some effort so
um but also and Novo had knew this but
we didn't realize it as much but it
became really really clear to us that
this team lead was super super important
so that you needed an active team lead
so when you sign up and you do the
organic teams the first person that
signs up or starts a team is the team
lead sometimes they don't realize that
the team lead a lot of times they don't
realize
um so for the second course we made that
more explicit we made that explicit what
the the role of the team lead would be
and Anne's going to add something to
this so that I
no I'm going to say that in because of
because we are
we are a team and especially when you
guys ran the mooc we were even smaller
um because of this finding we actually
changed the ux and the UI for teams so
that now when you decide to start a team
you're like messaged you were a team
lead here were your responsibilities if
you choose not to accept them it's like
the exit when you're playing right
so we'll see how that works yeah but it
was thanks to the work these guys were
doing
um
and then so some self-reported analytics
that we thought were interesting
the learning analytics were really
positive actually so the self-reported
learning analytics so at least 86
percent a big majority were at least
satisfied and a lot of those were like
very well satisfied with what they
learned in the course about the specific
topic but more important to us was that
76 were felt at least prepared to go and
change instructional practice in their
classroom so which is great I mean
that's that's the idea like if I could I
mean now whether or not that actually
happens you know that's something that
we need to look at but this is a great
result for us we were happy with it but
our team results were really interesting
right so teams were highly correlated
with completion and if you were on a
bigger team with more people you
actually had a much better chance of
completing but a lot of people were
confused about teams so 38 and also
before I talk about that it was very
interesting to us that 38 chose teams
that included their real-life colleagues
so that was kind of an aha for us that
this was already happening and we maybe
needed to do something about that but
then 30 percent thought that team aspect
was not really effective or not at all
effective and they had various
suggestions on how to change the team
aspect and actually
um and talked about one so there's
already a change in the team lead you
also made some other changes and put
Google docs on the team page so that
they could collaborate Gchat so that
people could have actually a video chat
so with their team they can you know
talk to someone and
um Brazil while they're sitting in Palo
Alto which you know we haven't done the
analytics on that yet but that it seems
like it would help a lot is there are
there other changes that
oh can you talk about that a little bit
so again just based on what these guys
were doing the scheduling tool which
seems like a dingy little thing is huge
for people so when they go in their
workspace they just fill out a schedule
that's a doodle poll right and then and
then they figure out when they can have
a chat and then they press start Hangout
and there's a record of that so then you
can go in and see who's hanging out when
and then you can also go in and look at
the docs so it just it's facilitating
what people want to do we didn't invent
we're not inventing Behavior we're just
trying to remove the barriers
and then one change that we haven't been
able to do yet but I'm hoping that we
can
um is one thing that people mentioned a
lot is that they would like to be able
to evaluate their peers on their team
which makes sense right because that's a
best practice in in teaching and
learning and that if you have this
professional learning team then it's
it's logical that you'd want to look at
their assignments and be able to
evaluate that rather than a random
person we
um
ask them to do that in the pilot mooc
but then that meant they were doing it
twice which is a little bit of burnout
and so we changed it a little bit in the
second one but hopefully you know
someday the we can make it so that they
actually do that so that was one of the
suggestions we're still working on but
here are some of the other revisions so
um the basically the hybrid option which
I'm going to talk about quite a bit
right now we also did a team experiment
intervention so we actually had a PhD
student who wanted to do an experiment
she's a condometrist and so she did a
team experiment and tried to kind of
manipulate a little bit to see if the
treatment teams had a more of an effect
but then we also added in from the
beginning so what the the session later
on today is called designed into the
core more useful analytics about
learning outcomes so we added in the pre
and post assessment there's a few other
things that we added in Joseph can talk
a little bit about the tool that he
added in an LTI tool which has been
really helpful and hopefully in the next
month will be even more helpful as we
analyze a lot of these to do the third
iteration
um and so here's the hybrid model I
don't know why I don't like to call it
Blended learning but the hybrid model
seems so much better so the hybrid model
is kind of what I talked about before
and the big part about the hybrid model
that I think is super essential to it is
that there's a need so we didn't think
about making the hybrid model it was
that districts and schools came to us
and they said this is what we want to do
we already have these professional
learning communities we love your mooc
but it's really hard for us to do our
thing and have them do the moocs at the
same time can we just work with you and
create this sort of hybrid model and so
what it is is it's basically people who
sign up teachers that sign up for the
mooc but the mooc is incorporated into
that school or District's professional
development model and so so for this
particular District what they did is
they had coaches instructional coaches
work as their Guides Through the course
and they met with their teams once a
week or sometimes twice a week they did
kind of a pre a pre-session as well to
kind of introduce them to the mooc and
then they also collected data through
the process so they could tell they
could help folks out if they weren't
doing so well
and then the experimental team
intervention so basically I'm just going
to talk very briefly about this because
I want to leave us some time for
discussion there was a control in a
treatment group and the treatment teams
received information about their
teammate stated goals per the
pre-assessment and pre-survey and the
control teams didn't but the control
teams did receive messages from us but
they were basically about people's goals
in general they weren't about your
specific teammates goals but both but
the treatment team was encouraged to
think about how their goals and
experience intersected with their
teammates goals and both so as I said
both the treatment and control teams
received equal number of messages but
the treatment was specifically about the
other people in their in their team so
it was very personalized right
so these are the outcomes the same ones
but with the last three uh with the
exception of the last one more focused
on
and here's our completion rates for the
other courses so you can see that the
the second iteration of the elementary
the completion rate was a lot higher was
like what 44. 44
um and the secondary and math
um were very you know in line with the
first one formative assessment was was a
lot less and there's a couple reasons
for that first of all don't ever try to
launch a mooc in May with your target
audience being instructors and teachers
is a bad idea
and second of all we wouldn't have done
it and unless we had had to and second
there were no teams which I find
interesting right so if you you're not
accountable to anyone so you drop out
you drop out
um and then but more interesting are the
hybrid completion rates I'd look at the
difference here it's it's probably
pretty intuitive but the hybrid in the
elementary was you know almost it was 84
percent I think versus 44 and the
completion rate for the hybrid model in
the secondary was 99 they basically had
one person drop out or 96 or something
like that
um so it makes it's a big deal they stay
in the course and it makes sense because
they have this kind of peer pressure
from the people that are in their real
life but they also have a guide guiding
them through that in a way that we
couldn't do we just logistically
couldn't do
and then some analytics about the team
intervention there's actually no
significant differences in the
completion rates between the treatment
teams and the control teams but really
interestingly and this is kind of when
research is counterintuitive
uh not this is not counterintuitive but
the the actual results are being on a
treatment team actually led to being on
a team for a shorter time and we kind of
were scratching our heads like what is
that about and becoming an auditor which
means you're not part of a team right
um but it also led to providing longer
comments on peer evaluations and um
wanting improvements in team discussion
boards and team formation process and so
the conclusion that we're making about
this is actually probably a good thing
because the being on the treatment team
actually makes you more aware of the
importance of the team and your role in
a team so if you can't hack it if you
can't you get your team members goals
right and if you're not hacking it you
feel guilty and you become an auditor
whereas if you're not on the if you're
in the control these these goals are
just kind of randomized they're not
personalized to the people that are
actually there
um and we actually had a similar result
between the hybrid so the hybrid overall
there's been significant growth between
in learning outcomes so between
assignment one and assignment three and
growth between the pre-assessments and
the post assessments which is great
that's what we want but interestingly
there wasn't significant growth between
the hybrid model and the non-hybrid
model in the learning outcomes the
measures that we use for learning
outcomes we haven't looked at the
classroom data yet the classroom
observation so maybe that will be
different but we thought it was
interesting that the actual the hybrid
participants were more likely to say
that they have not yet attained
discursive connoisseurship that they
need more they need to know more and so
we kind of scratched our head about that
for a while and then I was like oh it's
like being a PhD student so you go in so
I did you know a masters and I thought
that I knew a lot and then I go into the
you know my PhD program I hit year three
and I'm like I don't know anything
and I kind we think that that's what's
happening with these hybrid folks is
that they start to realize that this
overconfidence and under confidence
right so they start to realize the folks
in the online version may be a little
overconfident this maybe is not as
simple as we thought
and this is something that we need to
check in with our district Partners to
see if this is the conclusion that
they're coming to as well so I actually
take this as maybe a good thing because
it's building an awareness
um and then our current work and our
next steps is that we're doing
qualitative analysis Challenge and
another member of our team Lisa are
doing some qualitative analysis of Team
blog data so they're looking through the
team blogs remember how I said the
discussion boards were really heavy in
the first one and the team blogs were
really heavy in the second one so
they're doing a more systematic look
through that where they look through it
and find different codes and then we use
them and then we're also doing
qualitative and quantitative analysis of
the hybrid participant data so this is
the classroom observations these are the
the surveys that the district actually
gave so they gave like satisfaction
surveys as well which I thought was very
helpful
and then the big thing is we're
redesigning the third iteration of the
CCC moocs and that requires a lot of
things for the second iteration we
didn't change the assignments we didn't
change the assignment structure or
anything like that basically because we
didn't have time and so for the third
iteration we're trying to so we're
making changes to the assignments we're
always making changes to the team and
we're making changes to the discussion
board and different types of hybrid
models so for the next iteration we're
actually going to work with two
districts and they have different ways
of doing one's a huge District one's
like a medium-sized District the
medium-sized district has more capacity
to you know they can hold the hands a
little bit better so we'll see how that
works
so we just wanted to I know that we have
about 10 more minutes left we want to
open up for discussion questions again
about how questions about how we defined
and measured collaboration and success
how we redesign the second iteration or
maybe how we are thinking about or
should redesign the third iteration
um ways you've decided define success
that maybe we're not considering
and then this biggie how to get a
classroom application besides
um observations in the classroom so my
background is I do a lot of classroom
and out conversation analysis in
classroom so video analysis but I also
think that we really need to get at the
students as well
um so yeah we'll open it up
I keep putting Maps so I'm thinking
about scale and if you're working with
big uh school districts and wondering
how you analyze video like what grad
school massive Army have you amassed and
Stanford Mass
it is that how it's uh that that's
processed and tag right now in terms of
no it's not process integ we're actually
working on different video projects so
it's going to be process and tagged
after that one's done
um I don't know how we're going to go
about analyzing where basically we've
got some funds we're working with that
is it not teaching channel the other one
teachscape and so they basically are
designing a video library for us so that
we can use that video library not only
for the classroom videos but we can use
the videos that we're using um it for
This research and they may overlap right
so we may have the school district gives
us some videos and we can use them in a
future mooc but we can also use them to
look at whether or not this mooc was
successful
um and so those will be you know bagged
and tagged in the the video library that
and it's being set up so it should be
done in a couple weeks okay and just a
follow-up question for the um the
teachers that were looking for credit
from the district that you said that we
would do we as Stanford at school would
do the analysis of your work
um how many students it wasn't very many
what how many total was that or just
curious do you know it was like
20. okay yeah it was a I mean and part
of it was the way that we marketed it
but part of it was not as much
distinction between the paid option and
the pre-option I mean that's a big part
so we're trying to rethink like what can
we offer
with the paid option that is more
appealing to folks
um so we're doing some brainstorming on
that but as far as who will do the
analysis we have a bunch of Tas who will
do that too
yeah good questions
one more question yeah
um I guess quite a little logistically
question
um like so you have Hybrid models and
you have non-hybrid models but were they
in the same course so you had basically
one one session sort of running and all
of these different schools were using
the same course yep so they were in the
same course and basically we customized
the course for that District as far as
the scheduling goes so they want it at a
certain time they wanted three weeks
between each session instead of two and
so we customized it that way we didn't
have video from that District we had
California video which is a different
demographic of students but we did the
best we could
but we opened it up to everyone and so
there wasn't a whole lot of changes to
the actual you know the content you
offer on the platform itself
um to and so then other people could
take it as well I guess my real question
is that so based on what district I was
from I would see different content and
the Nova is providing that is it has
that capability
evidence
so they just say we want to do this
shall I write an email Brendan or I
write back and say Here's how you do it
awesome okay yeah so so right now like
we do a similar I do a similar thing
with my Pi on a computer science
education at Berkeley and we're using
edx and it doesn't quite have that
functionality at this time right so like
that's why I thought it was really cool
because what we we don't talk about it
exactly but it seems like what I'm
trying to accomplish is similar like
we're talking to different districts and
but I guess nobody has that
functionality to really customize what
it looks like which is awesome yeah it
but I mean as far as the videos go like
videos are similar there are the same
for for the district and the hybrid
participants and the other folks but
other content can be but we could I
assume customize that as well
so um so we just cloned the course we
cloned the existing course for them just
to save time and then it's but it's easy
they could have erased taken down videos
and put stuff up school districts could
it's so intuitive to load a video that
you can just do it with a touch button
so they could customize that they do
different clones then for different
districts or whatever no so okay so
that's what no we don't have different
clones for district different districts
we could but because of this first one
we didn't want to you know overwhelm
ourselves we didn't
um and so there so if you're in the
hybrid model you see the same videos as
if you're in the non-hybrid model does
that make sense
um
and the but they have people working
with them you know every week so if they
wanted to customize it in a certain way
they have ta access that they could do
that okay and it would look
the actual physical like the actual and
it's probably better to answer that okay
yeah
so we we have a I'm going to step back
another example that I think might be
more clear because now it's kind of
Muddy yeah um we're launching with the
Carnegie Foundation the pathways math
courses and we're rolling out uh 250
Community College classrooms they are
hybrid courses there is one master
course it's cloned instructors in those
classrooms can modify it
Carnegie doesn't necessarily want to
want them to modify it because then it
there's day there's data there are data
issues
um but that's different from what these
guys are doing so what these guys did
which is I think what you were thinking
of was that first model what these guys
did was they had a clone of the course
people could come in and use that but
they and they could make modifications
upload videos but that those changes
would be seen by everyone who was
enrolled in the course so so they were
using like a master even though that
Master was a clone so if you sign in and
you're hybrid you see the same thing as
someone who's okay okay that helps
back there
so so that was an interesting point
about the Carnegie foundation not
wanting certain things to be modified so
as you think about these relationships
with districts and the hybrid model are
you going to have like certain things
like hey look this is good research
evidence-based stuff it's locked down we
don't modify this area you know here's
your playground where you know it's a
little kind of gray or you can go crazy
yes
created another category so before you
either an instructor or ta and now
you're you can be a mentor and so the
mentors don't have modification
permissions
um
what we've found is that the districts
want to modify things beforehand so I
just met with a really big District
LAUSD and they gave me some suggestions
on some of the tools the analysis tools
that we've been using which but I think
most districts and maybe I'm wrong they
it's just too messy for them to want to
go and I mean if they did it it would
probably be on you know an accident but
they want something that they can use to
customize but they don't want to
actually customize the videos themselves
and I think um like for the change we
did actually for the second iteration
the change we made for our districts is
mainly on the readings they are there
are some readings that's specific to
their states or District that they want
to include in the course and also when
we talk about the videos I think here we
were we're actually talking about
classroom videos because we have
classroom videos demonstrate how
students use language to um demonstrate
their learning so that thing um that's
about the student population thing so it
could be it will be more helpful it's if
it's more relative to their school
district so that's the thing we are
trying to customize but for the master
content I think they will stay the same
I should say also that we had no videos
at all where it was like an instructor
just sitting and talking
um and I should have said that at the
beginning of the course but we do have
you know content videos and what we did
um is we basically made um screencasts
where we narrate some of the graphics
and you know let them read through so we
have a couple screencasts each course I
mean each session and then we actually
had teacher panels and higher ed panels
and then classroom videos and those were
what's the majority and what else also
interviews and interviews so we would
interview I guess that's close to as a
talking head as we get so we'd interview
so for example Margaret Heritage who is
a form of assessment Guru so we
interviewed her
anymore Joseph do you want to talk a
little bit about the tool that you put
into the second course so we can you're
better to talk about it than me
um
yeah do you maybe can I yeah yeah
you should introduce yourself too
so I'm Joseph Williams I was a can you
hear me fine like this I was supposed to
talk um in Santa's office for online
learning and open learnership with
kindness Hill
um and I'm moving to harvardx but um
they're one of the few people who are
education researchers teaching a mooc
and I found out what they were doing and
it was absolutely amazing best I've ever
seen so of course I want to be involved
and so on I was looking at their course
on um what I focus on is randomized
experiments so I was trying to think of
how to combine that with another
interest I have
um kind of based on looking at their
materials which are very much about not
just how do we teach someone something
so it's in their head but how do we
teach a teacher something so they
actually apply it so using the online
medium to bridge learning with actual
application performance in everyday life
and so can I pop up a link so there's
some area of research that can I do that
yeah
um there's this area of research um I
think Dick Clark mentioned this morning
a really interesting point which was the
things that we don't
okay I'll move it over but
yeah
um he said the things that we don't see
in the literature but that's because
actually
um they've been published 20 years ago
and you can't publish it now because we
know that right but that's kind of a
problem because I don't know how many of
you um read papers from that far back in
time so let's actually kind of rare
um
do you you mind logging in
so there's this area of work called
electronic performance support tools and
this is when pretty much somebody does
first became mainstream and the idea was
how do we Design Systems that actually
help us perform a task so it was often
used in settings like decision making
and nuclear power plants
um you know settings we normally think
about in terms of teaching or learning
every day but the main idea was what can
you provide someone as a tool an
electronic tool to help them perform or
make decisions or do an action and so
kind of looking at that
um
I was up inspired you think well what's
the kind of equivalent for something
like teaching and so basically I'm I
mean Sarah basically oops it's not
showing up
is this the first one it's um
okay let me just
I think it's the actual internet
connection not the okay I'm training in
front of demo it's
uh
okay so basically um this was Sarah uh
built this tool which was
um you actually could you explain what
she was for the Emirates um
so one thing I forgot to talk about in
the assignments is that
um so these they got in their classroom
and and did these observations and these
analysis and the analysis was based
around a particular analytic tool that
we created and so for the core the first
course it was a conversation analysis
tool so um a lot of times when we ask
teachers to go look at language their
first I mean it's it's what everyone
does their first thing they do is look
at grammar or pronunciation and we
really did not want that so we wanted
people to look at how students were
using language for the content areas and
so we created four different courses
different tools so that was the
conversation analysis tool for the math
course it was a math reasoning analysis
tool so how students were using language
to express their reasoning
um and so that's we call it the emirat
so there's the cat the rat the rat and
the emirat which we may have to change
because now we have a mathematical
argumentation tool and it doesn't really
lend itself it can't say a mat
um but so Joseph you did just you did
the matte imrad or you did the cat too
both of them okay
okay but basically all I did was um it's
actually a really simple idea but it's
basically how do you take what we were
going to say in a lesson and make a tool
version of that so you basically you
teach them a lesson then you say and
here's a link when you need to apply
that information just click on this link
and actually you just guide yourself
through and I just finally got through
20 layers of Stanford security to sign
into my account and I can show you
makes us do now
they send actually I don't know if other
universities do this but they send in a
text to your phone so that you actually
have to check the code on your phone and
then sign into your mail because they
are so security oriented now
um and if you have to go you know that's
fine but I think he's almost done yes so
basically all I did was take Sarah's
um tool and plug it into actually
somebody's interactive where you would
say to what extent the insurance and so
on you ate it what did You observe to me
think that to what extent did something
else and you added so it's actually
super simple all it is is taking the
content that she already had in a PDF
but put in the form of an actionable
worksheet where you can click on it and
they also told well
um you know you get this tiny.cc it's
kind of like bitly except it's not
popular so you can get whatever you want
it also allows redirects so tiny.cc icat
and so basically
um in there but basically then that just
pops you straight into this where
there's this toolkit to help learning
and so that's exactly all that is there
is this survey embedded into the page
and so the idea is now at the moment
that a teacher is going to teach a
lesson or review in today's class they
can actually click on that hyperlink and
go then use it so just as a design
strategy that was the the attempt what
we also did was um in the pre survey we
randomized whether people were
explicitly told about this link so
everyone got the tool but just in the
precautions some people are still you
know here's what this link is for try
and use it and right now we're seeing
that just that small manipulation
actually increased um how well it
performed the assignment
yep
so yeah yeah
that is a good question I don't know
yeah yeah
if they could use it
um because it was randomized I I think
probably some of them were but we should
find that out
um and we should also have people using
it in the future Hybrid models right
I could do some interesting experiments
all right I think that's it if you guys
have more questions please come up to us
later on but thanks for coming
yeah both of them are I couldn't find
somebody
else